[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
mais tant d'argent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entendez par la correction
jouer vraiment mercier mont bernard
d'amours d'être avec nous le président
la fédération française de rugby et
gaëlle fuit coup un héros merci bravo
quel
est ce qu'à bord le toit parce qu'on
parlait souvent rugby quand on faisait
l'émission ensemble et à chaque fois tu
dis est celle là je la sens bien que la
somme en mai à la haye ce qu avant le
début du tournoi tu sentais qu'il y
avait un vrai truc qui se passait je
savais qu'on avait une bonne équipe de
deux ça fait très longtemps qu'on n'a
pas une équipe comme ça brille ça fait
deux ans que ça monte cette équipe à l'
incompétence à maturité avec des beaux
mecs dont il fait partie c'est une
évidence il a plus de 110 sélections en
équipe de france mega llc 5e c'est une
humilité moi je le vois dans toutes ses
interviews dans tout ce qu'il fait et
c'est une humilité incroyable et tous
les gars de cette équipe de france on
sent que c'est ça aussi la force etc les
mecs ils ont une humilité el assad voilà
c'est engager quelque chose ouais c'est
alors que j'ai la nausée moi je les
entraîne pas et j'ai toujours aimé les
équipes que j'ai entraînées parce qu'ils
avaient des beaux mecs parce que si
esthétique j'aimerais l'entraîné parce
qu'elle est fabuleuse bien sûr l'état
d'esprit ordinaire des mec fabuleux
turcotte et hier soir il était encore
les trois quarts de l'équipe à rester
ils ont bouffé d'appareils en salle
n'avait pas envie de se quitter c'est à
dire ça mais il ya les frimas un vrai
truc il se passera quelque chose c'est
vrai gaël tu te régales c'est fou c'est
pour toi c'est un rêve oui vraiment
c'est énorme on a pris énormément de
plaisir comme l'a dit bernard on on se
régale on prend du bon du bon temps ce
sont 500 conscient dans cette équipe et
c'est ça vraiment on s'en tient pas là
il ya moins de pression on sent que vous
amuser ensemble vous êtes content de
vous retrouver ce que disait bernard et
si ça qui compte le plus apprécié le
talent bien entendu mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya une génération avec énormément
de talent là en plus donc c'est vrai que
c'est en plus et surtout on sent
vraiment que vous prenez pas pour des
stars non on est pas destin on fait
notre rêve on s'amuse on rigole et on
gagne sur tous les matches et c'est ça
au coeur du plaisir aux supporters c'est
le plus important pour nous un grand
chelem je vous le dis c'est vraiment une
vraiment une performance incroyable
mokhtar qui est fan de rugby c'est ce
que c'est il ya quelques années ont
franchement on se disait c'est
impossible c'est vrai il ya bernard ya
trois quatre ans déjà on se disait que
ça les nst compliqué non mais non on a
vécu dix ans d'autres non bien sûr c'est
ça
le dernier titre c'était en 2010 douze
ans qu'on n'avait pas gagné ouais donc
on attendait encore une fois de remettre
d'abord l'église au centre du village
c'est à dire que il a fallu pendant
quatre ans se battre avec la ligne vers
sur le rugby c'est à dire est que pour
trouver des conventions de parce qu'ils
appartiennent et la profession de la
nation aujourd'hui c'est la réussite de
tous leurs unis france et de la
fédération des clubs professionnels et
avec la commission qui dit il lui qui
nous lie c'est un ensemble de choses
avec un staff on n'a jamais le staff
aussi compétent fabien galthié à la tête
arrêts tous les mecs vous avez joué sur
sûr vous allez jouer sur la longueur
fabien ça fait longtemps qu'il est là et
c'est vrai que voilà il a construit
cette équipe il a construit ce succès
aussi un fabien galthié et vous n'avez
pas cherché à changer quand ça allait
mal voilà vous avez des sites voulez
l'essayer prix travaillé ils travaillent
ils travaillent depuis des années fabien
pour arriver à cette performance
aujourd'hui ouais exactement et puis
pour leur montrer que j'avais confiance
en eux fabien est un soc à vendredi j'ai
alors ce qu'on appelle la remise des
maillots avant le match rituel du rugby
et je me suis levé le matin je me suis
dit il faut pas attendre dans la
victoire de mai ou la défaite de demain
pour dire jours pour l'autre jour
prolongé par le staff c'est trop facile
ça s'est lâché nations ont gagné ouais
ok je te réponds quand je suis arrivé
j'ai dix personnes au courant mais la
fédération personne n'y a que moi qui
l'ait décidé ce matin sabine sera avec
nous jusqu'à 2027 abbas était ainsi de
confiance d'abord parce que c'est tout
bon train c'est la première chose est
sûre et gilles fabien je m'en fous c'est
enfin on sait pas ce qu'on va faire dans
deux semaines
de 4,1 et donc c'est moi c'était une
marque de confiance d'abord un des ses
joueurs et puis surtout en lui parce que
c'est quand même le seul cas bien sûr
alors alors on va revoir les nombreux
essais qui a eu dans ce match regarde
[Applaudissements]
sûrement joie des joueurs cités
on te remettre à faire françois trausch
relève ce ballon c'est le temple hill
[Applaudissements]
au départ marque schott magritte encore
lui d'un lot
[Applaudissements]
toutefois
tu trouvé un instant comme vous voyez
l'action la gagne ça doit vous faire un
truc hein mais c'est toujours des
émotions c1 mais quand on y est on y va
en a on a l'impression au début ou pas
du tout vous aviez l'impression sur son
masque plus émotionnel on l'a toujours
la pression
c'est incroyable petit stade était en
feu on savait qu'il y avait énormément
de pression sur nous donc c'est pas
simple on habitue déjà aussi beaucoup la
pression au quotidien donc elle a fait
on était sur un coeur mais la ccvo c'est
votre plus belle victoire à west ham
j'en étais deux millions et demi de
téléspectateurs pour la plein de
questions à vous poser j'aimerais savoir
si vous avez est ce que le tout le monde
vous appelez bernat vous avez l'image et
du chef de l'état monsieur le président
laissez un message dix minutes après la
fin du match à disputer l'équipe non je
crois que ce qui s'est passé ce qui se
passe depuis depuis six mois avec cet
effet les marseillais mais je me dis
bien là je veux venir ça je veux vivre
la marseillaise c'est trop beau c'est ça
c'est une chose de fou non mais c'est
vrai que même moi qui je suis mais comme
un choix car je joue pas je ne donne pas
je suis là mais maintenant les cas la
marseillaise qui avait 80 mm
c'est fou tiens l'ambiance de fou c'est
vrai que ça c'est des moments
incroyables c'est pour ça que vous avez
fait ce sport gagne ça ça doit être des
moments qu'on a envie de vivre bien sûr
c'est un rêve bon soyons on va revoir la
remise du trophée 10e grand chelem
regarde
deux grands chelems privée la7 coupe
elle est à la maison ce soir à l'est
drik formidable écoutez le stade de
france au moment où l'autre dupont
ir ciotti si m grand chelem français
[Applaudissements]
bravo
bravo vous qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter maintenant ce qu'il faut leur
souhaiter chez le champion du monde dans
un an et demi c'est ça voilà il y aura
d'abord un tournoi des six nations sur à
donner un nouveau ton et surtout
l'événement ça nous coupe du monde en
france ça gaël selref basse et c'est la
compétition qu'on attend tous c'est ce
qu'on s'est dit encore hier on a dit on
a fait quelque chose de grand hier avant
de chair à l'est le reste ça sera la
couleur grâce à m cinq ont presque vendu
la folie c'est bah 22 2 millions de
gilbert saint pourçain de billets terme
ici sur cette soudaine et glee et
bernard je suis très heureux pour tout
de suite et je dirai un mot nazi
mont-bernanchon celui qui lève la couple
un break du prix antoine duquesne
c'était un accès terrestres c'est un
extraterrestre
j'ai rarement vu un joueur de cette
qualité il a 23 ou 24 ah ouais c'est
romancé jeanne variables ces déchets ne
savent pas qu'ils sont vierges en génie
sa foi qui soulèverait ici par lui
jamais le mec avec de trois heures
winter's d'amour aussi bobo chic
talentueux et sa mécanique folle quand
il est toujours là quoi la rive le gros
match mais qu'il est bien là exactement
toujours là il me rappelle 10 ou 20 ans
avant d'en faire un match comme ça on en
a on n'en est rien il ya 23 ans donc on
va en valais on va en faire des coupes
du monde avec lui j'espère bernard bravo
je suis très fier s'est redressée
heureux pour toi ce que tu sais comme je
t'aime et comme tu le mérites parce que
tu lâche rien en plus tu lâches rien
montbernard c'est pour ça qu'avec jeunes
qui arrivent toujours ben bravo à toi